la diabetes tipo 2 es una afección en la
cual su nivel de azúcar en sangre es muy
elevado después de consumir alimentos
con carbohidratos
los químicos en su intestino delgado los
descomponen en moléculas únicas de
azúcar llamadas glucosa
luego la membrana de las células de su
intestino delgado absorbe la glucosa
qué pasa al torrente sanguíneo
cuando la sangre llega al páncreas las
células beta dentro del páncreas
detectan los altos niveles de glucosa a
fin de reducir el nivel de glucosa sus
células beta liberan insulina en su
torrente sanguíneo
a medida que la sangre circula a través
de su organismo la insulina y glucosa
salen del torrente sanguíneo a sus
tejidos para alcanzar las células del
organismo la mayoría de las células del
organismo tienen determinados receptores
en sus superficies que se unen a la
insulina en circulación
la insulina actúa como una llave en una
cerradura para abrir la célula a fin de
que la glucosa circulante pueda llegar
dentro de la célula
ahora sus células pueden utilizar la
glucosa para producir la energía
necesaria para funcionar en forma
adecuada
si tiene diabetes tipo 2 su páncreas no
produce suficiente insulina o las
células de su organismo resisten sus
efectos o ambas cosas
si tienes resistencia a la insulina su
insulina no puede desbloquear las
células para dejar ingresar la glucosa
porque los bloqueos llamados receptores
son anormales o están faltantes como
consecuencia la glucosa queda encerrada
fuera de sus células por consiguiente la
cantidad de glucosa aumenta en su
torrente sanguíneo en una afección
llamada hiperglucemia
para compensar la hiperglucemia su
páncreas produce más y más insulina
sus células beta sobre cargadas de
trabajo intentan mantener la demanda
pero pierden gradualmente su capacidad
de producir insulina suficiente
debido a la hiperglucemia y la falta de
insulina puede experimentar los
siguientes síntomas clásicos de diabetes
hambre excesiva sed en exceso más
volumen de orina y pérdida de peso sin
explicación
los síntomas de la diabetes tipo 2
pueden aparecer con el tiempo incluso
cansancio infecciones recurrentes
cambios en la visión picazón y
cosquilleo o picazón en su piel
las complicaciones que ponen en riesgo
la vida de la diabetes tipo 2 incluyen
cetoacidosis diabética síndrome
hiperglucemia hiperosmolar no se tóxico
e hipoglucemia
si no recibe tratamiento para la
hiperglucemia puede derivarse un acceso
a sido si es diabética debido a que no
tiene más insulina suficientes
circulando en su sangre sus células no
pueden obtener la glucosa que necesitan
para producir energía como consecuencia
su sangre se convierte en grasas y
proteínas como una fuente de energía
alternativa
durante el proceso de desglose de grasas
algunos subproductos conocidos como
cuerpos cetónicos se acumulan en su
sangre y esto resulta en una afección
llamada cetosis si las cetonas aumentan
peligrosamente a altos niveles en su
torrente sanguíneo puede desarrollarse
tu acidosis diabética o cda que puede
derivar en un coma y la muerte
otra complicación que se deriva de una
falla para tratar la hiperglucemia se
llama síndrome hiperglucemia
hiperosmolar no se tópico o hh ns a
medida que la deficiencia de insulina
continua su nivel de glucosa en sangre
aumenta como respuesta sus riñones
filtran el exceso de glucosa fuera de la
sangre en orina junto con grandes
cantidades de agua
a menos que consuma grandes cantidades
de agua sus riñones no podrán mantener
la demanda de eliminar la glucosa de su
torrente sanguíneo y la diluirán en
orina en forma suficiente como
consecuencia su sangre se convierte
mucho más concentrada que lo normal una
condición llamada hiperosmolar y that la
hiper osmolaridad arrastra el agua de
sus tejidos del organismo a su torrente
sanguíneo lo que ocasiona una grave
deshidratación que puede derivar en
síndrome hiperglucemia hiperosmolar no
sé tópico los síntomas neurológicos como
convulsiones y coma
pueden aparecer
si ingiere una medicación para la
diabetes excesiva puede experimentar una
complicación aguda llamada hipoglucemia
o choque de insulina la insulina
excesiva un medicamento hiperglucemia
oral causan demasiada glucosa en las
células lo que deja un monto
insuficiente en su torrente sanguíneo
algunos órganos como el cerebro
necesitan un suministro de energía
constante para funcionar en forma
adecuada debido a que la fuente de
energía del cerebro es la glucosa este
es el primer órgano afectado por los
bajos niveles de glucosa
cuando sus células del cerebro llamadas
neuronas tienen gran necesidad de
glucosa empiezan a funcionar mal lo que
causa síntomas como nerviosismo temblor
y confusión si su nivel de glucosa sigue
bajando
la actividad eléctrica de sus neuronas
disminuye en forma significativa y tiene
como consecuencia convulsiones o coma
diabético
con el tiempo la diabetes tipo 2 mal
controlada crónica puede causar daño en
el tejido degenerativo que tiene como
consecuencia complicaciones a largo
plazo como arteriosclerosis ceguera
neuropatía e insuficiencia renal
a fin de evitar las complicaciones de la
diabetes tipo 2 puede tomar medidas para
mantener su nivel de glucosa dentro del
rango normal mediante el uso de una
combinación de control de glucosa en
sangre una dieta sana ejercicio regular
y medicamentos según sea necesario
deberá controlar el nivel de glucosa en
su sangre en forma frecuente con un
glucómetro para realizar esto se
pinchara su dedo con una pequeña aguja
llamada lanceta y colocará una gota de
sangre en la cinta del glucómetro
considerando su nivel de glucosa en
sangre quizás deba adaptar sus comidas
actividad física o dosis de medicación
consumir una dieta saludable ayudará a
disminuir su nivel de glucosa cuando
consuma una dieta rica en frutas
verduras y granos enteros realice sus
comidas y meriendas a la misma hora
todos los días
consuma el balance adecuado de
carbohidratos proteínas y grasas y
minimiza su ingesta de alimentos altos
en azúcares la realización de ejercicios
en forma regular incluso solo 30 minutos
al día disminuirá su nivel de glucosa en
sangre disminuirá su resistencia a la
insulina y podrá derivar en la pérdida
de peso
quizá necesite uno más medicamentos para
la diabetes para ayudar a disminuir su
glucosa en sangre algunos de estos
medicamentos aumentan la producción de
insulina en su páncreas
otros disminuyen la resistencia de
insulina en sus músculos esqueléticos
algunos tratamientos aumentan la
sensibilidad de la insulina en
determinados tejidos otros promueven una
leve disminución en la absorción de
glucosa en su sistema digestivo
si su diabetes tipo 2 no puede
controlarse con dieta ejercicios y
medicamentos orales su médico puede
recetar insulina y capacitarlo para
aplicarse inyecciones subcutáneas
al tratar y controlar su nivel de
glucosa en sangre puede evitar la
ocurrencia de complicaciones de la
diabetes tipo 2